[Music]
in this epic then there is in general
presented to consciousness what is
implicitly
accomplished in the cult the relation of
the divine to the human
the content is an action of the
self-conscious essence the acting
disturbs the tranquility of the
substance and excites the essence so
that its simple unitary nature is
divided and opened up into the manifold
world of natural and ethical powers
the action is the violation of the
peaceful earth the trench which animated
by blood evokes the departed spirits and
these thirsting for life receive it in
the action of self-consciousness
the business which is the object of
these general exertions has two sides
the side of the self by which the
business is accomplished by a totality
of actual nations and the individuality
standing at their head
and the side of the universal but by
which it is accomplished by their
substantial powers
formerly however the relation of the two
bore the character of a synthetic
combination of the universal and the
individual that is of picture thinking
on this specific character depends the
appraisal of this world the relation of
the two is thus a mingling of them which
inconsistently divides and apportions
the unity of the action and
superfluously throws the action over
from one side to the other the universal
powers have the form of individuality
and hence the principle of action in
them what they affect appears therefore
to proceed entirely from them and to be
as free an action as that of men
consequently both gods and men have done
one and the same thing the earnestness
of those divine powers is a ridiculous
super superfluity since they are in fact
the power or strength of the
individuality performing the action
while the exertions and labor of the
latter is an equally useless effort
since it is rather the gods who manage
everything
ephemeral mortals who are as nothing are
at the same time the mighty self that
brings into subjection the universal
beings offends the gods and in general
procures for them an actual existence
and an interest in acting
just as conversely these impotent
universal beings who nourish themselves
on the gifts of men and through them
alone get something to do are the
natural substance and the material of
all events and are equally the ethical
matter and the pothos of action
if their elemental natures are first
brought into actual existence and into
an active relationship by the free self
of individuality they are no less the
universal that withdraws itself from
this connection that remains
unrestricted in its own specific
character and through the invincible
elasticity of its unity it faces the
atomic singleness of the doer and his
constructions preserves itself in its
purity and dissolves everything
individual in its fluid nature
paragraph
730 is quite a long one there's a lot
going on in here that we need to unpack
it's linking together what has happened
in the
three paragraphs preceding it in this
section the spiritual work of art and
it's getting us ready for what's coming
next so a lot as i just mentioned a lot
of different moving parts you could say
to this
or as hegel would call them you know
momentum right
aspects of things and i do want to start
with something that comes in about a
third of the way through just in part
because it probably catches
everybody's eyes because hegel so rarely
uses terms like thesis and synthesis
in the
phenomenology of spirit
and as we know of course you know the
hegelian dialectic does not proceed by
way primarily of thesis antithesis
synthesis with the next synthesis being
a new thesis that's all sort of nonsense
uh picture
you know sort of fill in the the dots or
paint by numbers that's not real hegel
right but he does use this word
synthetic here he doesn't say synthesis
right he says synthetic synthetic
and here he talks about a synthetic
combination as miller's translating it
a perfectly good translation there in
the previous paragraph where he brought
this up he talked about um
there was a synthetic linking together
and
the the other term that he was using
there and is coming up in this paragraph
as well
is
what's being translated as picture
language i do want to point out
something that's a minor detail so in
the previous paragraph
it was forced a long
right and now it's for stalin
i don't think you have to make too much
of that for stellang comes from
forstellen this is a composite verb
stellen is to like put into place it's
sort of like the greek histay me or
there's a latin
connected verb as well
and for right in front you know so
something that is being presented to us
it's not quite the same thing as darsh
delang
which miller has been translating as
presentation
or presenting
but
stellar can be translated as picture
language it it's also much more often
in uh not just hegel stuff but in german
philosophy and and culture generally
translated as
representation and that's a good way to
think of it as well there is a
a content there that is more objective
than just our our feelings or sensations
or
our actions the places where we are
here he's going to connect this
directly in terms of the
the epic or apos in in german
with the cult that it's being contrasted
against and out of which it's coming as
well
so
i wanted to point this out at the start
um
you see it here at the bottom of the
diagram but that doesn't mean that it's
last place or anything like that so
let's let's take up what what hegel says
here he begins by saying
in the epic then there is in general
presented
and here it's it's a
verb that's broken right stellen
in this case stealth dar right at the
end of the
phrase
it's it's presenting to to what to
consciousness but sign
the consciousness of the believer but
also we could say there's a little bit
of haunting going on here and when i say
haunting i'm being a little bit
facetious the spirit
is involved in all of this stuff that's
happening in the paragraph and on both
sides of the self and the universal the
human beings and nations and gods
we're also spirit
observing this and there's a couple
places in here where you can say wait
represents or presents or
shows this to who well to to us
anyway going on
there is in general presented to
consciousness what is now here's a bit
of a mistake in translation implicitly
accomplished in the cult so
we'll talk about what is that but what
implicitly just means on zeke right
it is um
accomplished it it arrives
in the cult it happens in the cult for
the cult members on zeke in itself
not yet
for itself not yet in a completely
conscious way let alone in on and for
physique uh mode so the cult has been
doing something but the epic is doing
that thing in a different way
doing it in terms of representation
representation through language language
and images not just statues festivals
flowers garlands
uh
you know
dramas or things like that
what is it representing what is this
content
so this is really interesting
this should make us think for a bit
is hegel
talking about all epics
here
in
in saying this what what is what is the
relation that he's saying he says the
content
or what's being presented is the
relation the zeong
of the divine to the human the interplay
between gods and human beings
now let's pause for a moment and think
about that
okay the greek epics
like
the odyssey and the iliad sort of the
paradigmatic epics
um yes there's lots of gods involved as
a matter of fact the gods even take
sides
for the greeks the hellens or for the
trojans and they interact with each
other as i mentioned in a previous
paragraph
diameters is even able to spear
not artemis uh aphrodite who's on the
side of the trojans in part because that
uh
athena sets her up for that um and
there's all sorts of other things going
on as well i mean gods fall in love with
humans and humans in love with gods and
all that what about the anaid the the
latin epic yes okay that there might be
more
human
interaction there but it's still a
divine
world
if we're going to call other things
epics
like say beowulf
grendel is a son of cain
and there's a biblical reference there
is there much talk about the gods not
really
in a way that's that's a kind of godless
world or maybe there's the high god you
know bob
kind of dim
um
do we have other epics in which the gods
play an important role i mean we can
think of later on epics like the
portuguese epic uh
um by kamosh
the lucid dads right
where there's all sorts of greek gods
involved as a matter of fact uh
aphrodite if i remember is the patroness
of vashgodagamish and um dianisos is the
bad guy and christianity and islam are
also mixed in there as well so okay
sometimes we have that if we want to
talk about epic fantasy which which is
something that's happening after hegel
but would be useful to bring up
like in the lord of the rings or
the prince of nothing series or the
chronicles of pretend or pick whatever
else you want
do we have gods and humans
that's a good question i'm just going to
leave that open and we're going to move
on so he says what is this content it's
an action
and here he says
in previous paragraphs we pointed out
that we'd expect to see han lung and
instead we're seeing tun now we actually
are seeing han lung an action a
a sort of coherent intentional action
of the self-conscious essence
and what is the self-conscious essence
is it the divine is it the human well
it's both both our self-consciousness in
relation to each other
he goes down and he says this acting
disturbs the tranquility of the
substance and excites the essence
so that its simple unitary nature is
divided and open up into the manifold
world of natural and ethical powers
okay that's important right
so we have we have this like everything
going along swimmingly
and we're all part of one big ethical
substance and then boom there's a split
and not just a split but splits we have
not just a duality but a multiplicity a
manifold monic faulty
world belt
of natural and ethical powers and we
talked about this previously with the
pantheon right the pantheon
uh is is the gods that you know the
totality of the gods that it includes
the natural and ethical powers
we talked a little bit about whether it
actually includes all the gods or just
some of them we're going to put the the
ones that aren't included to the side
for the time being and how are these
arranged in relation to each other not
through an ordering
a systematic account like the sort of
things that we give afterwards when we
have little kids and we're like well
zeus is the god of this and hera is the
god of this and apollo's the god of this
and we got 12 nice neat areas and they
don't really overlap well that's
[ __ ] that's not the way the pantheon
works at all right that's sort of cookie
cutter stuff that we give to to kids
because we think that the kids are too
stupid to be able to figure out the fact
that the gods rival each other the gods
don't get along all the time
and if we look not just at the greek
gods but we look say at the babylonian
myths and other mesopotamian myths or
you know the norse or uh
you know uh the the
stuff that's being represented not just
in the vedas but the piranhas if we look
at this stuff in a wider perspective we
see that pantheons are messy things they
are manifold
right there is no one single structuring
principle
that
naturally and ethically
puts everybody in their place
hegel doesn't actually exploit that
he could have done that were he
nietzsche he probably would have right
think about nietzsche and the birth of
tragedy or nietzsche and some of his
later works uh but he doesn't and so he
he instead brings up this homeric
metaphor which is quite cool and and
where is this coming from this is coming
from the part of the odyssey where
odysseus
has sailed with his his comrades those
who are still left who haven't died yet
because they're all gonna die pretty
soon um
to the land of the dead
into hades
why to consult teresius the seer who's
dead
and he sees other people he sees ajax
who hated his guts and died uh
humiliated after trying to uh you know
kill
odysseus and ajax won't talk with him he
sees achilles the greatest of the greek
heroes who says man it sucks down here
you know he sees his mother he sees all
sorts of people
in in that book of the odyssey and what
enables the dead to speak he has to dig
a trench
which then he fills with blood
and i think he sprinkles barley meal on
top of it if i remember right as well
so
hegel says the the action
the handling
is the violation of the peaceful earth
and the trench which animated by blood
evokes the departed spirits these
thirsting for life receive in it receive
it receive life in the action of
self-consciousness so this is kind of an
emblem for
what happens when when action is taking
place han look
action is always you could say
controversial
uh in the sense of
turning
verture right
things uh together but against each
other as well opening up
wounds opening up
scars opening up a trench that blood can
flow into
which then can be consumed
well let's not dwell on that too much
because it actually it's a nice image
but it doesn't really do much here
let's go on
now hegel here we get to the real thing
hegel says the business the the geshefta
which is the object of these general
exertions has two sides so now we go
typical hegel fashion from a complex
manifold to there being
two sides that he's going to pick out
hagel does like to work with dualities
quite a bit
um
the side of what the self zelpst and
the side of the universal the argument
so the self he says is by which the
business is accomplished
by what a totality
of actual nations peoples
fulcrum right um and
individualities standing at their head
now notice he doesn't say like and every
single individual in the nation or in
the people
no it's the ones that are standing at
the head the ones who stand out the ones
who become the objects of the epic does
it mean only the single person who is
ruling
take the the iliad for example what do
we have at the very beginning of the
iliad after homer says you know single
muse
of what the wrath of achilles oh
achilles must be the the head no
agamemnon is the head and achilles wants
to kill that bastard again agamemnon who
has deprived him of his prize and he's
going to go sulk and let the greeks you
know get kicked in the teeth by the
trojans until somebody comes to bring
achilles back in unfortunately after his
friend and lover patroclus
dies
as a
result of this
it's
not just the one individual who stands
at the head it's the notable individuals
who are part of the story right
and very often they're connected with
each other in in different ways
so he says that we've got that as one
side
the side of the universal
now notice what he says by which it the
business is accomplished by their
substantial
powers
is the in is the uh singular for that
and substantial substance sup sanstia
right so these are the gods and here now
we get a really
interesting interplay that's going to be
happening between them
throughout the rest of this paragraph
so here we also get to the discussion he
says formerly
for hin and we'll talk about that in a
moment formerly is not really the right
way to say it he's just referring back
to the last paragraph
just a little while ago
uh the relation of the two
bore the character of a synthetic
combination of the the universal and the
individual that is of picture thinking
what what is the connection between
picture thinking for stellang
and
the universal and the individual well
the the universal can be represented in
the individual by representation
right and the individual
whenever they're acting as an individual
also has something of the universal
in what they're doing and that's why
their action their handling is
intelligible
so
there's a very important connection
there
he says on this this specific character
depends the appraisal
urath island
of this world a judging
of this world
judging of what world
the world of the epic the world that's
being presented to us just think a
couple paragraphs back by who
by the minstrel the zenger the bard who
tells us
of this amazing world that we are
not a part of in our wake a day world
right
our world of work
and
taking care of our family and going off
to school and catching the train or
whatever it happens to be doing the
bills
it's instead of par it's a fantasy world
you know
so
he goes on and he says um
the relation of the two is thus a
mingling of them
which
inconsistently divides and apportions
and now remember i talked about the
unity of the action
apportions the unity of the action
splits it up and superfluously throws
the action from one side to the other
how so
here's hegel talking about this
basically through the rest of the
paragraph
the universal powers
are not just universal they have the
form as he says of individuality and
hence the principle of action
in them what they affect appears
therefore to proceed entirely from from
them and to be as free in action as that
of men so what zeus decides to do
is up to zeus what you know if we take
another thing from the odyssey
um
odysseus is is basically screwed for a
large part of the book because he has
ticked off poseidon it was a very
powerful god right because he blinded uh
the cyclops uh paula mephis
and uh as he was sailing away said hey
jerk you know it wasn't no man who did
this it was odysseus remember that when
you can't see anything you jackass and
then you know uh the cyclops praise to
his dad and he's like hey dad do
something to this guy and uh poseidon is
like i'm gonna i'm gonna stick it to
odysseus and anybody who hangs out with
him right
and he does until zeus finally
intervenes and zeus intervenes in part
because athena who
actually loves odysseus is like hey
hasn't this poor guy suffered enough
let's let the guy get home right we
killed every we
either killed everybody else off or they
manage to screw things up for themselves
this guy should get to go home these are
free actions by the gods right
so
he goes on and he says consequently
both gods and men have done one and the
same thing this is another good point
too i mean the greek gods are pretty
human-like uh they just have a lot more
power it's not like you know zeus at
some point is like you know my ways are
beyond your can o mortals no we can
understand zeus quite easily he can't
keep his you know his peace in his pants
he likes to go around and cheat on his
wife he gets involved in all sorts of
things that aren't really his business
he's in charge of these other gods who
you know are quite frankly uh very
powerful but kind of screw-ups um i
think we can relate to him quite easily
well maybe not the screwing around part
right
but the the other stuff
and we can think about hera can we
relate to her can we relate to
hephaestus the poor worker guy who gets
kicked around and treated badly you know
and
we can go on and on and on
so he says the earnestness of these
divine powers is a ridiculous
superfluity because they are in fact the
power strength of the individuality
individuality performing the action
while the exertions and ladder labor of
the ladder is an equally useless effort
because it's rather the gods who manage
everything and now so we get get at one
side where it's the gods that the story
is really about the gods
human beings are just these poor little
checker pieces getting pushed around by
them have you ever seen the classic
clash of the titans there's this this
scene where there's a chessboard and
zeus and somebody else are playing it
and they're moving the the monsters and
the heroes around on the chessboard
is that really the case
so hegel says
ephemeral mortals who are as nothing
are at the same time
the mighty self that brings into
subjection
the universal beings offends the gods
and in particular
in general procures for them an actual
existence and an interest in
acting
so i mean on one level human beings this
is actually kind of camusian in a way
human beings can know that they have
freedom and agency because they can at
least piss off those mighty immortals by
not doing what they want people to do
and they do this all the time in every
religion basically if you look at their
mythologies
and he goes on and he says
just as conversely these impotent
universal beings
who nourish themselves on the gifts of
men and through them get to get
something to do
are the natural substance and material
all events and are equally the ethical
matter and the pothos of
action so you know
you could ask why do the gods need
sacrifices what are they getting out of
it
why sacrifice a hundred ox and a hecatom
so that zeus can like sniff it in
oh that smells good you know uh the the
fat and you know certain bones and
i don't have some organ meat and stuff
like that
um and we talked about this before with
the cult right human beings love those
kind of sacrifices because the gods
don't get everything and the priests get
some of the stuff and the community gets
some of the meat as well
but
why do the gods need this
because the gods are in a very radical
way dependence on human beings dependent
on worshipers for their very
reality
in human lives if everybody stopped
caring what hera thinks or says she
doesn't matter anymore you know we've
got our technology to take care of all
of these things that we used to pray to
her for in the household
we don't care she's no longer part of
the picture
or part of the story
hegel goes on and he says if their
elemental natures the gods are at first
brought into actual existence and into
an active relationship by the free self
of individuality
they are no less the universal that
withdraws itself from this connection
and remains unrestricted in its own
specific character
and through the invis invincible
elasticity of its unity
effaces the atomic singleness of the
doer and his constructions preserves
itself in its purity and dissolves
everything individual in its fluid
nature
how is that going to happen we're going
to have to see
as we move through it there's this
restoration of the substance the the
unity of what's going on but on both
sides we have
human beings and their nations
and then we have the divine and this is
being again
depicted
put forward stealth right whether it's
for gestalt or dar gestalt through the
language of the epic
the epos
speaking
later on
writing as well but tapping into our
imagination
tapping into our own human capacity for
making thought and language interact
with each other
so we can ask ourselves what's actually
being depicted here in the
epic this is what hegel thinks is is
important about what's going on
in an epic it's not just let's go get
helen and kick some trojan ass and fight
some people on the way and maybe you
know argue about war captives
there's something more essential going
on here
that hegel thinks is a cultural
achievement i would say too again we
i've made this point many times i'll
close on this point what's going on in
the greek epics can be seen as going on
in epochs in all sorts of other cultures
and civilizations as well
you